[Music]
BOM dia NDC Porto was set to be an
international conference with people
travelling in from all corners of the
world we were looking forward to
visiting the beautiful city by the
Ribera
but unfortunately that's not possible
the health and safety of people will
always be our first priority when life
throws you a curve ball it's how you
react that matters cancelling the
conference was never an option not for
us and not for you thanks for sticking
with us hi guys remember we're also
available on slack in case you guys have
any questions there's also a WebEx
meeting in the info booth for you guys
to reach us in person estamos & Co
suspect available to all the speakers
that are ready to present to you from
their homes we know you were all looking
forward to affront to Gina we'll have to
say that for next year thank you so much
for speaking to all our fantastic
partners thank you for staying with us
in this difficult time
these are awesome companies a special
thank to our main partner for fh4 has
more than 60 people attending our
conference and workshops also thanks to
Cisco for providing us with free
licenses to run all our events on WebEx
thanks to our fantastic portal crew
sergio andrea sergio gelareh ma yu lian
Liliana you did a fantastic job so where
we are in the world we hope you enjoyed
the show
anything you want to add to this Dylan
yeah hey hi first thank you to all of
you for making this possible our
sponsors partners speakers and attendees
we planned a lot of amazing things for
2020 and running Porto as an online
event certainly wasn't one of them but
thanks to all of you we've made it
you're awesome the world has changed so
much over the last few months the last
thing we wanted to do is to make it even
more confusing for anybody so we've
tried to stick with simple tools and
formats that will work for everybody
there is a slack workspace for NDC
Porter 2020 if you're in slack you're at
the conference it's as simple as that
welcome all of you we're using WebEx to
stream all our talks all our sessions
and hang out together online NDC
wouldn't be NDC without the hallway
track and all the great conversation
that takes place there and just because
we're online is no reason to change that
will be sharing links in slack
throughout the day and in the evenings
to various tracks sessions and social
events if you want to see a conference
session click the link and join the
meeting switch on your camera mute your
microphone and give our speakers a nice
big smile we're all presenting two
webcams in our spare rooms it's kind of
weird but being able to see your faces
makes a huge difference and please laugh
at our jokes even if they're not very
good a virtual conference is never gonna
be the same as a physical conference but
there is a bunch of stuff we can do here
that we could never do before I know
there are people watching who would not
have been able to join us in Porto in
person welcome all of you were really
happy we're here you don't want to go to
a conference without any shoes on hey
you can do it now there's no queue here
for the coffee machine
nobody has lost their luggage and if you
want to you can curl up and you can
watch the keynote on your sofa with your
cat so get online and get involved join
sessions join the chats be excellent to
each other let's make this awesome now
it's my great great pleasure to
introduce our opening keynote speaker
like many of you I remember the days
when you didn't even mention Microsoft
and open source in the same breath and
yet here we are
it's 2020 dotnet is a free open-source
framework running on Mac OS Linux as
well as Windows supported by a
fantastically rich ecosystem of tools
libraries and platforms it's the heart
of a thriving developer community and
our
opening keynote speaker is literally one
of the people who made that happen
please give a huge NBC online welcome to
the one and only Scott Hanselman hey
friends not yet not yet not yet not yet
not yet yeah the ten was a lie and nine
eight seven six five five four three hi
friends this is weird it's like a
virtual keynote I'm so nervous
it is one o'clock in the morning and I'm
in Portland Oregon not what I want to be
and I know that you also are not where
you want to be but I appreciate that
you're spending time with us here at an
NDC this is pretty special stuff hello
to everyone on YouTube and on the chats
and in this life all the places that you
are I appreciate you all spending time
with me and also for my studio audience
the speakers who have let me stare at
them so that I don't have to talk to
myself in a strange room while my wife
is in the other room wondering what it
is that I do for a living
this is pretty exciting stuff I really
appreciate the technology in the effort
and I wanted to say thank you so much
for the team to put this together it's
really complicated to make something as
professional and classy as this I think
it's pretty pretty cool so thank you to
Dylan and Martin and all the friends
that put this together my name is Scott
Hanselman you may know me from the
internet if you followed me on Twitter
you're probably disappointed because you
went there for technology content and
you ended up with something else but
that's okay if you're not familiar with
me and the stuff that I do I'll take a
brief moment and just let you know what
I like to talk about you can go to
Hanselman comm and you can learn about
me or you can go in google with Bing for
Scott and find out
we're what I'm all about I've been
blogging for a number of years now in
fact if you go over to my blog and you
click on date it turns out I have been
blogging since 2002
that's 18 years of blogging which is
just nuts in fact if you go and look at
one of my years I'll just pick 2019 for
example and I'll just start scrolling
down a little bit it turns out that I
I'm kind of a creature of habit I
basically blog every Tuesday and
Thursday every year for 18 years and
then I've also got a podcast at a
podcast called Hansel minutes
Hansel minutes is called Hansel minutes
because I'm an extraordinarily bad
estimator Dylan knows this if you ask me
how long something will take I'll say 30
minutes we'll lean in knowingly and
they'll say is that Hansel minutes or
actual minutes because it's probably
gonna be about three hours and this show
is something I'm very proud of because
I've done over seven hundred and thirty
episodes for 14 years every Thursday so
why am i showing you this is it for the
free advertising partially but really
what it is is I realized that I'm
basically running a little business here
right it's not a business that makes me
any money this is a business that
basically sells ads to pay for hosting
but someone made the comment to me
recently that it looks like it's quite a
sophisticated setup I've got my podcast
I've got all of my mini sites the blog
20 years of content there's sites for
books it's kind of like Hanselman
incorporated if I had a business and any
money and someone actually emailed me
recently and said can you put me in
touch with someone on your team and I
was like I don't feel like I was gonna
put the one phone down and pick the
other phone up and say hello this is
Scott and sales let me put you through
to Scott in marketing right and now that
we're all trapped in our homes I was
realizing that I have more power than I
thought
not as Scott internet person or Scott
programmer with a lot of Twitter
followers but as Scott micro business
owner I've got this tiny little thing
here my blog my site's about 16
different websites if you go in search
for get involved in tech comm I've got a
a two hour documentary that's a free
movie that you can watch that I did with
Rob Connery that will talk to you about
how to become a social developer that's
one site a number of years ago I wrote
up a website called baby smash and you
can actually it's not for smashing
babies it's it's for for actual babies
to play and learn how to like you know
play with the computer and it's super
fun and these are all websites that need
SSL Certificates
and they need care and feeding I realize
that I've built a garden a garden of
things on the internet and in fact if
you actually search for Square Foot
Gardening for programmers it's very
specific square kind of square foot
gardening I've even got blogs on how to
do that I've got this garden of websites
there's all of the sites that I maintain
for myself and Hanselman incorporated
and I say that in quotes but there's
also all those stupid little one pagers
you know those little one-page sites
that you do just because I made a domain
because you know I was on Twitter and
Ian said something funny and I
registered the domain and now it either
is a website or it's just a failure it's
just a representation of my failure this
domain that I registered I never did
anything with one of my joke domains is
keys left dot-com where I can type in
you know how old I am and how fast I
type and it'll actually calculate
exactly how many keystrokes I have left
before I die I have two hundred and
fifty three million keystrokes left
before I die
and this is really important because
that means I can either write 84 novels
or I can write a million and a half
emails to my boss so it gives you a
sense of what you really want to do with
your time so we're all trapped at home
I've got all these websites there was a
time there was a time
and these websites were running on a
server that I could visit and a server
that I could touch and by touch I mean
like the cloud before the cloud you
would go and see your server some of the
younger people may not remember that but
you could go you said where's my server
you go to the big warehouse the big
Costco Winco macro kind of place and you
say where's my server oh it's on row
nine just walk down there and you go
down to the row and you put your hand on
the server and you could push refresh on
your laptop and you'd feel the server
shudder because there was a spinning
circle of rust that would start and grab
your disk off and would say yep that's
the server and you could say my computer
at handsome accom is on that rack on
that server and that refrigerator in
this row in a building but with the
cloud it's not like that anymore is it
you can't visit your computer anymore
well Hanselman comm has actually been
running on a server in Ontario for a
very very long time and I was running it
was the last machine that's been running
in this particular server and that
company was a hosting company that got
bought by another hosting company that
got bought by another hosting company
and recently I was on the Twitter and I
search for a firm Hanselman server down
I think it was and I was having an issue
where my computer went down and let me
see if I could find that website down
blah blah blah maybe just search for
down it was handsome calm and it was
spinning that I ministers for spinning
rust ah
I think the spinning rust virtual
machine that has run my blog for 18
years may have died two weeks before my
migration to the cloud this will be a
live disaster recovery thread so then I
started talking about how I was gonna
move to the cloud is a 15 year old web
site running dotnet to write daunting it
too and people would tease me every once
in a while I would get on Hacker News
and some I would say something there was
a time when I wrote an article once
called URLs Rui I was telling it when we
need to care about our your eyes it
should be crisp and pretty URLs Rui
isn't the kind of hacker newsy thing he
would go straight to number one and what
was the first comment on Hacker News
this from a man with aspx in his
extension how dare you even imply cui
you don't even get to talk like they
just they dismissed the entire article
because they had aspx than the extension
I thought was actually pretty good it
was because I saw this article in the
paper with a specific a specific URL for
you to click so the computer went down
and it was very sad and again this is a
15 year old piece of hardware so here's
the deal I tweeted about it and then I
called the folks that run that server
and I said hey I think the computers
down can you help me and they said who
are you and as I have Scott Hanselman
I've been I've been hosting my my blog
at your web site for 15 years and like
no no no we got bought by some lovely
French Quebecers who are you I had been
grandfathered in and grandfathered and
grandfather and I realize I haven't even
paid a bill in years they'd forgotten
about me and I was actually in a
computer under like Anna's desk
somewhere oh let's ask Anna she was here
back in the day let's see if you're
under her desk I was on a computer under
the desk that with and post-it note on
it that just said don't delete this at
Scott's
literal physical spinning rust when I
tweeted this that my site was down I
tried to call tech support and they
didn't even believe that I was at their
company I had to ping and traceroute to
prove that I was hosted and it turned
out that one of the individuals that
follows me on Twitter this really
actually happened one of the people on
Twitter who follows me happened to be in
the NOC the NOC is like the network
station they were actually doing
maintenance on the machine and he went
over to the machine and he jiggled the
why
on the back any DM to me I'm really
sorry I know this is not professional I
apologize I'm actually in the room with
your server right now I'm gonna jiggle
the wire and get it back up the server
came back up and I know I'm in the
process of moving this to the cloud okay
so here on this website that says URLs
Rui I think to myself how would a
company deal with that I'm I'm Scott
Incorporated but I'm only one person one
person with one server in one place
but I want to be international I want to
have global load balancing in the cloud
I want to have CD ends and all this kind
of stuff and I want my URL to not have
aspx and the thing right well if you go
to a URL like that right now and then
you put the word staging in front of it
okay I hit enter
aha now now I'm ready to go to hacker
news and not well and they'll just be
mean about something else but the point
is they won't be mean about my my URL so
when you're running a little business
like this you got to think about all
these things a 302 or 301 redirect SEO
all the things that could go wrong no
robots.txt I want to do it in a way
that's scalable and easy but I'm also
want to learn about the Internet while
I'm doing it and this has been such an
exciting journey to go and move a 15
year old blog engine it actually seemed
known in that it's called das blog
anyone remember this das blog it's
German for the blog das blog you have to
say it with like a German and it was
originally built by Clemens fastest with
German lovely German man you know it's
okay for me to talk like this because
Hanselman is a German name was - ends at
the end we came to America took away one
of the ends and now - blog is being
converted by a lovely man named Mark
Downey - Blagh core so das blog here he
goes there's papa string so he and I are
building das blog in a way that will run
on
on on Linux on Windows we're doing it
with with dotnet and with asp.net and
that's cool and then Hansel minutes is
gonna need to go over to the cloud as
well so I'm slowly slowly moving all
these things to the cloud but then
things got really complicated I've got
my home page which is brochure where
I've got my slash blog which is a web
site and I've got slash speaking and
slash part these are all mini sites some
of them are pages and whether or not
maybe it should be I mean think about
this you're all writing this in your
heads well maybe it should be a static
site generator maybe you should use
Django you know well you could do this
and you could do that like it doesn't
really matter
as long as the URLs are clean right I
could switch the whole thing over to
URLs as I say URLs are you ID honest yes
I could switch the whole thing over to a
static site generators or github pages
but I I don't want to lose my legacy I
don't want to lose this every link
matters right every link matters so I
started learning about ways to go and do
this so I thought I would spend a little
time showing you how I've been doing
this development and what makes me happy
and how I feel like I'm just a whole
company but I'm just one person like I
don't have a build person or security
person or cloud person it's just me and
I only have 67 dollars in credit and
Azure that's another good thing if you
ever meet somebody from Microsoft who
tells you all about the cloud and
everything and then you find out that
they never actually paid for anything
before they only do it in free credits
don't trust them always pay for always
pay for your own stuff so this is the
Hansel minutes dashboard the first step
in becoming a an official real company
and feeling like you're important even
though you're just one person in a room
in Portland Oregon is you get a cool
dashboard and if you're really fancy you
buy a television set a really cheap one
and you put it up on the wall and you
put the dashboard on the wall and
ideally if there's a map of the earth
with dots that show all the different
countries that you're in it's even more
impressive I like to say that I have a
global office
Starbucks any any country in the world I
put together this really cool dashboard
to give me an idea of how much money I'm
spending and I'm really really cheap
like I don't want to spend a lot of
money you know 20 bucks here or 30 bucks
there anything I can do to make this
thing work so while you might say hey
Scott go to a site a static site
generator in fact what we end up doing
is we just cache everything 20 years of
blog stored entirely in memory makes it
really fast and it's never been knocked
over for traffic and this is a an
example let's see if I scroll how fast
our friends at WebEx can capture all the
different stuff you're doing so it's a
lot of content a lot of great content
going over many years okay so what I did
as I started with a thing that I just
learned about called front door as your
front door it's kind of like CloudFlare
super cool so what this lets me do is
design my front end I've got my staging
in my hands muncom so I got production
and staging all right
and then I've got back-end pools
remember how I said the main site is
different from the blog one and then I
put in rules here I'm learning about
whether or not I want to force HTTPS or
have blogs with slashes here are the two
main routing rules here and then when
you have this one here that's blog they
take care of paying for the HTTPS I can
go and put in patterns and it's
basically lying to my app and doing the
automatic rewriting and what's called X
dash forwarded headers get automatically
passed in and the real blog is over here
go to blog and we'll say Hanselman blog
look o see this one here remember I told
you I have a lot of websites this one
here is an extremely important website
that is my son's website he made it in
their studio code and it's very
important details about about Rubin the
hamster
and also we got I think that a copyright
issue with with the YouTube video anyway
that's also very important is running in
a container in the cloud
okay uh app service here we go so
sometimes you go here yo this is here oh
hey canceling blog you can see the
traffic and the data out and moving
around when people go and learn about as
you're one of the first things that they
do is they say I want to make a website
and they go make a new website and then
it's like 50 bucks
Oh Microsoft with a dollar sign you suck
and then they just delete it and they go
off and get add I know it I don't know
Heroku or whatever right well it turns
out that Asscher and people at Microsoft
are really bad at naming stuff because
when you make a website in Azure it's
called an app service not a website that
would make too much sense and when you
make a VM where you can put websites
that's called an app service plan not a
VM it's actually a VM I am notoriously
cheap as we have all said and not only I
am German but I'm also half Scottish and
Scots are well known for being
incredibly cheap you'll never catch
corona from a Scot because the Scot
never gives anything away and here here
I've got two app services I've got one
on Windows and one on Linux let's let us
zoom in just to prove it that's the
proof that that's running on Linux so
I'm just gonna put as many arrows as I
can around it okay now look look at this
I've got 14 applications running in my
main server farm and I got four in the
other it's surprising to me when people
start thinking about the cloud they
start thinking about it the way they
think about virtual machines oh you know
this computer we've got this virtual
machine it's got like 40 percent
utilization 60 percent utilization we
need to start thinking about capacity
planning when you think about capacity
planning we should have more space to
grow but when the cloud it doesn't work
that way you should work that machine
into the ground you should make it work
hard what do I have a lot of on this
machine I've got a ton of CPU this
thing's not even trying it's not even
breathing you could beat on this and it
would never hit 10% cuz I cache
everything look at this I'm barely
hitting 40% memory 16 different sites
full it's just loaded up with memory
because when you go in here and you look
at these app service plans which
irreligious virtual machines what you
got to do is ask yourself what do I need
and how much do I want to spend I'm
spending more money here sitting double
what I used to I used to buy a 2gig one
I don't care about the perf I wanted the
four gigs I ran that's the deal
I'm loading these things up I've got
like 16 18 websites running on two
machines and I could probably probably
shove them onto just one machine and in
fact that is going to be my entire goal
my goal is to get all these 14 machines
all these 14 apps here on windows over
to Linux because it's 20 or 30 percent
cheaper right I'm gonna have more perf
I'm gonna have a faster thing notice
that I'm actually getting the premium
SSDs for the same price windows cost me
on standard so I'm slowly making my tiny
companies maneuver over to Linux here
but remember back to das blog das blog
runs only on Windows right cuz doesn't
it - so we slowly started moving it we
started moving and I started moving it
and I started moving my my podcast so
let's go out here to github and let's
look at Hanselman first here's Hanselman
calm and let's look at Hansel minutes
here's the code real actual code okay
this ly I'm using by the way I'm using
Windows terminal which is just yummy I
love it I cannot say enough nice things
about it you should get it and you
should have really cool
prompts and stuff as well because it's
the best okay so here's Hansel minutes
notice this here I've got the docker
build docker run what's going on there
let's go take a look at that let's look
at a type docker build what is going on
there
you know what that's called everyone
this is a Linux ism that people just
take for granted that's a shebang that
hash-bang there at the front called a
shebang tells us that that power shelf
that power shell extension windows does
everything based on extensions that
Linux would much rather be told
explicitly what to do in the first line
of the text file that's ignored because
it's a comment on Windows but it's used
on Linux which means that I've actually
got a PowerShell build file that works
on both Linux or Windows which is super
interesting and useful and it'll come up
in a second so then I can go and say
docker build I'm on Windows right now on
the D Drive and it says hey talking to
docker right that's cool so it's gonna
go and it's going to build my little
application it's doing the build on
docker and what I'm in fact doing I'll
open up another tab so I've got my build
over here okay and I'll come out here
and I'm gonna save WSL - guest list - of
e you can see I've actually got a number
of Linux as running in WSL - one of them
is in fact docker itself so I'm on
Windows using the docker desktop talking
to the docker that's running within the
context of wsl if I say Windows docker
images I see my docker images from
Windows but if I go out to let's let's
close some of these and let's open up
here look at all my lovely choices let's
pick Kubuntu and let's go and say hey a
boon - and let's safe docker images and
then I've got my doctor images we are
sharing the exact same docker context so
whether I built it in Windows or built
it in
in from whatever weather I kick off the
docker building Windows or Linux it
doesn't matter so there you go I just
built that okay so there I built my
lovely multi-layered docker thing and I
can go and run that I now can do
something else that I've really been
enjoying lately what if I did docker
test I could actually go and run a build
and then this is a horrible thing but
this is the kind of horrible thing you
do when you're in one-person shop if his
windows right it all comes down to a
horrible switch statement where you make
a judgment call if it's Windows do this
otherwise it's that this is where we get
into the whole argument about slashes
versus back slashes this is a longer
conversation that we won't be having
this morning but I want to point out
though that docker tests ps1 works
everywhere the other thing you might say
is why would you use PowerShell power no
one uses power shell I'm not using
PowerShell here this is bash right I'm
over here in in Ubuntu I don't care
about PowerShell from a shell
perspective I care about it from an
automation perspective that's power I
need anyone where's PowerShell oh it's
off somewhere else that's often in
whenever I didn't put in the path I'm
using PowerShell as a as a script Runner
more than I am for a a shell ok now
let's go and run test instead and let's
do some tests and see if they run I
haven't tested this in a while maybe
this is not even gonna build let's find
out we'll do a test not on docker but
rather we'll do one on the metal and see
how much trouble we get into here and
let's see what's going on test run it's
thinking I hear fans turning on things
are freaking out pause for effect
something's gonna happen what's going on
the disk is happening see the circle of
patience is this the demo that's going
to fail this is not really a demo it's
my actual website which would be even
more tragic as if it was one thing it's
one thing to fail at demo is another
thing to actually not be able to build
your website at any moment
hang on hang on what's what's that WebEx
you're covering up the demo working on
another screen scandalous so what's
happening is the test runner has spun up
selenium weight on another screen what
it's been working all the time it's
actually loading up a local version of
my podcast look at this look look look
look look look what what what yes chrome
is being controlled automatic test
software we are currently watching
selenium Hanselman has test coverage
good night everybody
that was the show here I'm actually
using coverlet which is a lovely dotnet
based test coverage application and I
wit and I passed all of my tests who
says Hanselman doesn't test 23 tests
ship it straight to production
that's certainly enough tests to go
directly into production right it's
still it's a decent amount of tests it's
pretty good I'm pretty proud of myself
some of those tests are selenium tests
and some of those tests are functional
tests and some of them are integration
tests there's different layers in the
testing onion as our friends at NBC
conferences well know so how are we
doing this right what's going on let us
open this in Visual Studio code shall we
visuals do I've got two applications one
is tests I made one called selenium
tests again behind every great function
is a hack that you've buried in a static
this is called in docker or build server
in the class are we are we because we
ask ourselves are we dot in docker or
build server and then we go and we look
at a couple of things first thing I look
at is agent name which tells me whether
or not I'm running in the context of
hazard DevOps and did you know the
dotnet say mean things that you might
about the dotnet team they actually make
an environment variable
all dotnet running in a container when
they're running in a container and
that's how you know makes it really
really easy so then I start up selenium
as part of the test which I'm very proud
of then I make a a trait in X unit
that's called skip when live unit
testing so visual studios background
testing isn't popping chrome windows up
frantically and then I love this line
line 100 it's always line 100 look at
that look at that
look at them look good and look at him
are we in a build server get out of
there so that means if we run that exact
same test in docker which would not be
able to then pop up a real version of
Chrome it would need a headless version
of Chrome or Phantom j/s or any number
of different little things hello Lucas T
Stephens a boss has just shown up to to
watch the session I appreciate that
I love having an audience docker test is
gonna go and run the exact same stuff by
the way I love these I don't know about
you but 3d accelerated ray tracing fine
impress me with an ASCII progress bar
I'm that guy I love a nice ASCII
progress bar don't you you know what I'm
talking about Michael you feel it it's
good look at that you're just like if
you put an ASCII progress bar in your
application it means that you care it
means that you care and that you want
people to feel good about the experience
at the command line
I want more I'm a slash for boast person
I want to talk I want slash slash slash
V not slash q we don't need any of that
what you want to not you want a no funny
thing about those little command-line
things you get that really hard that is
no it's that is why you need a carriage
return without a new light because if
you print a carriage return it takes it
beginning of the line you got and you
can draw another one when I love it
that's why we need it that's so that's
why that's why I always fail this is why
I like you Dylan because you add value
here's the thing my friend that's a
perfect segue as I build as I do my
tests to my youtube channel with my new
exciting playlist
called pause for effect called computer
stuff they didn't teach you in school my
first episode
what's a carriage and who's feeding it
lines what encouraged you to check out
if you would like to know what a
carriage is if you are under the age of
50 and you want to know who's a carriage
what's a carriage what's happening I
talked about typewriters because when
you have a git issue when you've messed
up an entire repository with whitespace
and it's all your fault
it turns out it's because they needed a
code to tell the carriage to return and
feed the lines it's just tragic tragic
stuff all right
ooh look look friends what's happening
here why did I skip four tests because I
don't have a chrome in the docker
container and I'm too lazy to hook up a
headless Chrome to do the work inside of
there with no UI but I'm learning and
I'm having a good time with it what's
cool about this is I've proven that I
can run this in dock wreck around
Windows I can run it with and without
heads everywhere it runs it works next
step let's make it automatic so let's go
to handsome in that vision coming there
the best part of this whole thing and
all the learning that I'm doing is
remembering that I'm just one person but
when you have great unit tests and you
can go get clone and build you feel like
at least three people you know I mean so
if we go to here you go here's my this
is my Azure dev ops and I've got my blog
my website my podcast and my blood sugar
system you can learn about my artificial
pancreas if you want to go in Google for
Hanselman diabetes you learn all about
that go to Hansol minutes and we can go
and see all the fun stuff that we're
doing let's look at our pipelines look
at that I've not only got unit tests but
I've got a lovely CI CD and this is the
best part look at this PR Zod I knew how
to do the arrows anymore PR automated
this is how you make one person feel
like multiple people let's
my secret github to my fantastic private
not for you people not this is totally
I'm not giving you my reason it's
private it's not because the code is
interesting it's because you're all
gonna steal the CSS and I paid someone
for that and I don't want you to take it
look at this this is when you imagine
this my friends you are social
distancing you wake up in the morning on
a private repository and you have eleven
pull requests and you say to yourself
self how do I have eleven pull requests
I was asleep who is doing these cool
requests ah dependable have you used
dependable Dillon if you experience the
joy and the wonder that is dependable
not voluntarily it just popped up one
day it's so cool it's a person that's
not a person that looks at your
libraries and sees that they changed
updates them for you makes the best PRS
and when I say best PRS I'm talking
about well chefs kiss PRS you know I'm
saying let's look at what a gorgeous PR
I love that I've been talking that's
gonna pause for a second and look at a
question that just came up on YouTube
because this is important individual
just said the most impressive thing so
far is the ability to make custom arrows
on the screen I just want to say that I
have I have moved a 15 year old blogging
engine from dotnet to into Linux into
the cloud scaled it globally put
together a CI CD I've got depended by
putting in PRS for me I've got it
running on with W sell on Windows on
Linux and your impressed with the arrows
and I appreciate you because those are
actually being those are actually coming
from from zoomit josé queiroz though
these come from zoomit from our friends
at a sumit
from mr. Russinovich so check out zoom
it that is how I'm drawing on the screen
but I'm glad that you are unimpressed
with this the global elastic scale of
the cloud and rather impressed with my
arrows okay check this out look at this
depend a bot okay
dependable made a comment two days ago
uh you should bump this from this
version this is the best look at this
here you open it up they actually go and
dig out the release notes link to them
and copy paste them in then they
actually figure out the commits on the
previous version to your version
inclusive and then list out the commits
so you can tell what they changed and
whether or not you should upgrade so
freakin cool then then you can talk to
it ok look at this see what says oops
depend a bot where'd it go commands
check this out you one individual who
has no employees can then go hey depend
a bot go ahead and rebase that or you
know close this PR reopen this PR or
ignore this talk to me when it's a major
version the power that we as individual
humans have now even in these difficult
times when we are stuck in our homes and
my little tiny mini business here the
power of automation is just so unreal I
just love that someone a bot is doing
this for me I love that I can check in
code and it will build in the cloud and
deploy to the cloud into staging the
idea that I even have a staging site is
so far from the way that I used to edit
stuff directly an FTP in production and
then just hit refresh and hope that the
site didn't fall over the power of
automation is such a joy for us right
now that I want to kind of like remind
you that it's a thing remind you whether
it be things like containers or the
cloud or open source what a joy what a
wonderful joy let me also show you one
other fun thing that's not directly
related to Hanselman comm but it's so
awesome that it has to be talked about
let's go out here so I'm on wsl we
talked about this the windows subsystem
for Linux you can prove it by running a
CH top if it makes you happy you can see
that there's in fact processes over here
that are talking to docker desktop
and if I go in here and let's see you
have anything in this folder
ugh dude no I don't do I have dot net in
this thing match version I do have a
version of.net let's go and make a Dylan
is nice and we'll see Dylan is nice okay
it's an empty folder new web okay I'm
gonna go file new project command-line
edition that's what that is
and now I've got stuff now where am I I
am in Linux okay I'm gonna say code dot
to be clear this is Linux I'll then oops
what am i doing click the wrong button
okay
then I will go code dot and I will run
Visual Studio code from Linux there's a
stub now watch watch watch Visual Studio
code knows it was launched from a boon
to but it's in Windows if I go file open
what file system is that what file
system is that that's the Linux file
system here if I say show local this is
the windows file system
what Visual Studio code has done is it
has run a server if we run back over
here and we run a CH top let's see where
our server is see if I can
to do something maybe I can get this to
build and in the output of this it was
running there it is a remote server it
runs a it's splits Visual Studio in half
has Visual Studio windows Visual Studio
server and why is that interesting let's
close out of here let's go back to
Windows what if we go over to something
like do I have go okay check this out
this is Windows I do not have go on this
computer I'm on Windows I do not have go
I got a go programmer code dot hopings
up Visual Studio code it says this is a
developer container why don't you do
this in a container sure let's do that
let's move that guy reopen in container
look at the lower left corner says
opening remote starting dev container we
are now in a container and if I go here
and I say IO dot I have full go because
I'm running in the context of the
container that makes sense so now I can
hand this folder to Ian right or to
Jessica and say here and then it's open
it and all the tool sets that they need
are there because if you look at the dev
container the jason has two things first
the docker file with the toolkit that it
needs and this is the cool part what's
this these are extensions Visual Studio
code extensions but where are they
installed I don't want to clutter my
machine my machine is lovely I don't
have messed it up so what we do is we
separate the local extensions go is only
installed in the container that cool so
that auto installs the extensions you
want in the context of the container and
remotes them so any extension in Visual
Studio can live
both locally or not those servers are
actually running in the context of this
container right here see those are the
node processes that are talking to
visitor to your code and then there's
some ghost stuff really create stuff so
then extrapolate extrapolate to what
kind of damage you could do if you went
to something like this actually let me
not login with work I'll show you what
I'm paying for cuz I don't want to be
the guy that does demonstrations and
doesn't pay for it where is my other
browser there you go let's pull this one
over here online oops
online business to Viacom sign in and
while I'm doing that I do want to call
something out though this is interesting
a gentleman said that's a simple lift
and shift it's actually not there's more
than is more there than a lift and shift
I'll talk about that in a second but I
want to point out here I've actually put
a development environment let's say that
I don't have a big machine a big beefy
computer I can instantiate one in the
cloud but I'm not going to remote
desktop into it that would be course
that would be like oh yeah you made a
virtual machine a remote it into it but
right instead what if I could actually
open that turn this on boot that up and
then do the exact remoting trick that I
just showed you and let all the
compilation happen in the cloud so you
could be on a Chromebook or a 300 or
Walmart laptop and make a machine that's
you know per second building and link
building in the cloud connect to it
oh how do i officials to you of code or
I've been stunned which one do I have
there's insiders and there's Visual
Studio code let's try that again so when
you connect to it you have like your
plan you can figure out like what plans
you want so over here I can say I want
to go and make a new plan
and it's gonna be this big it'll be a
Linux machine that's super-powerful yada
yada yada we'll spin this up in a second
here and a one there is a VM right and
this is the thing right I mean it's that
they're just so bad at naming it's just
unreal why that's not letting me connect
I may have changed my what I want
let's see if we can go for over here I
want to go back over here and I want to
say connect it remote there's all these
remote things that you can do there it
is remote containers close remote
connection this is all just an extension
of Visual Studio code which is a lovely
remote containers to online I think I
didn't you install a Visual Studio
online
yes online extension there goes business
to do online blah blah blah did I say in
think so
I think I you wonder if I'm blocking it
at the pie hole I have a pie hole which
is a we gotta come and come through on
YouTube sign click on the link not on
connect so you might you might want to
try to open the link click on the link
not on connect apparently well I clicked
on the link try both both this one will
go into the environment this way which
is Visual Studio code in the browser
thank you for that Dali appreciate your
help
let's go and do that while I'm doing
that this is again all in preview so
this thing changes every couple of days
because they're they're releasing new
versions all the time it's that right
there where this should actually be vs
code colon slash slash it's actually a
protocol handler so that right there is
one of my extensions that's mad at me or
it's an edge IAM thing this
the whole URLs a user interface and if
the protocol and the URL doesn't work
then they the user interface just fail
right working when you when I do those
clicking the link right in here what I
would have done of course is jumped over
individuals to do code like we just saw
and it would have connected remotely and
in this case here this is in fact das
blog now let me get back to the point
there where Christian was saying it's a
simple lift and shift yes it would be
incredibly naive to simply pick up a
virtual machine that was sitting on
anything and then stick it into the
cloud that would be lame
why would I do that so let's talk about
legacy code very briefly because I'm
running out of time
legacy code is a funny thing my friends
when you've got something that's super
old but it totally works you tend to not
want to break it and my blog is one of
those things so where is the database
for the Hanselman
a blogging system for the last 20 years
you may ask well it's in here pause for
effect I love that some of you are muted
and I can see you laughing which is
lovely yeah so it's basically 5,000 XML
files in a folder right because that's
how you roll when it's 2001 and XML is
the new hotness you laugh now but I know
you have JSON files in a folder and you
think that your curly braces are so much
better than my angle brackets so
boo-hoo-hoo okay now lift and shift to
the gentleman's point on the chat would
actually be yeah pick up a virtual
machine and put it into the cloud yay
good job kudos to you but how can I move
my stuff into the cloud potentially in a
more sophisticated manner setting me up
for future success well putting it on a
virtual machine would be kind of in fine
putting it in a port in a docker
container would make no sense
why because the data needs to be outside
the docker container I want to do a
mapping right well what we did what we
did is we moved our application from
running from running on windows on iis
to running in Linux on kestrel which
can run in the docker container I deploy
it into I committed into github it goes
over and gets built into Visual Studio
Soumya azure devops rather and then we
go to the blog here it's actually founds
my blog look at this figuration path
mappings we lie to our old application
and we said this folder here points to
an infinite as your files share what
that means is I can go into the azure
storage Explorer and map the azure
storage this infinite disk in the cloud
and copy all of those files over there
which is super interesting right that
means that all the data is completely
externalized from the application but i
didn't have to tell the app that i
didn't have to teach the app that i
literally lied i want to point out also
to our friend who may have shown up a
little bit late there
Mulla inglis our digital unless you have
as your free pass from being an azure
employee a Microsoft employee this is
not an azure free pass this is my actual
personal asher and i pay for it with my
own money and it comes out of my credit
card i'm happy to show you the bill i
don't get free as your money but i
appreciate you bringing that up because
I've actually done a series of blog post
if you go and search for Hanselman
penny-pinching in the cloud did a series
of blog post about how cheap I am and
how I can save money in the cloud so
definitely not doing that for for free
cool so then like this blog content this
is as your storage Explorer see where it
says four thousand five thousand cached
items all the XML lives there
that means it's redundant remember at
the very beginning of the conversation I
talked about how you used to be able to
visit your disks I can't anymore my blog
doesn't know that it's moved from dotnet
on Windows and I
to.net core open source in a docker
container in a linux machine in the
cloud somewhere that moves around and
the xml files that it calls file dot
open on they don't even exist anywhere
near it they're on an azure share
somewhere so through a series of lies we
call them abstractions in the software
world as we lie to this system we
actually go from being a simple lift and
shift to being a really creative way to
move a legacy application in the cloud
the next really interesting bit as we
get towards the end of the conversation
is the images where do all the images go
well not only are there five
thousand-plus XML files there's actually
thousands more images inside of that
blog content folder and those images
right now have only a couple of their
hard-coded basically like it's handsome
calm slash blog slash images yadda yadda
yadda
and there's gigabytes and gigabytes of
these images how do I put them on a CDN
this is where it get it all goes to heck
this is where if you've been offended
already you will be you know you're like
this guy can't code and at all if that
sucks let me show you how bad I can suck
and you may let let he and she who has
never worked in a legacy system cast the
first stone let me just tell you that
until you've worked on a machine that is
older than you let me just say be
empathetic be gentle be kind if I show
you the I want to say it is almost done
it's gonna be it's gonna be crazy
code dude to do opening code tests just
it is in a file called jinyang blog item
all right
dylan drink this in tell me what's
happening on line 31 and why it's both
genius and a horrible
that's string replacement yes it's all
because it's always a string replacement
there's two ways to solve this problem
go into the database writer regex and
steal every single reference to this URL
in 5000 files and replace it to a new
one that's the one
when you say database there you're
talking about a huge folder full of XML
that's 50 years old
database in airports base right your
other option would would also mean I
could go in in a rewriting module so I
could capture every single moment where
the browser asked for that URL but then
I cost it would cost a 301 redirect so I
need to catch it on the way out not the
way in like it would be interesting to
grab it on the way in but what I want is
to do is I want to catch on the way out
so again I drop every single thing into
Azure storage okay and then I make a CDN
the hansel CDN and what hansel CDN does
is amazing pat myself on the back
because look I just make these
subdomains and I go and say where's the
origin where's the origin for these
things you know it's just this CDN so
instantly what happens is the entire
blogs every image on the blog gets
replaced and sent off to the CDN the
whole site gets faster because the blog
images are now stored in Portugal and
not in Oregon everybody wins and then
one day and then here's the best part
you put in to do really need to fix this
but but not me someone else you know
someone who's not me but I will get
around to eventually going and replacing
that okay and I think that's all my time
but I wanted to just talk about how
lovely it is to be a one-person shop and
get all of this stuff working I remember
20 years ago getting whose control net
just started and we were just doing
extreme programming and and in unit
testing on net
and I just love that everyone has a
every language done that Ruby a Python
everyone's got a great unit testing
framework everyone can enjoy get
everyone can enjoy unit testing and I
appreciate Christian and our friends who
are playing sarcasm with me here on the
chat I appreciate you giving me talking
points and I appreciate you also letting
me tease you gently knowing that it is
all with a sense of love and and in
community we do we have two quick
questions and yes the more about your
Windows terminal setup oh so one of them
is is actually it's a question from me
so on your the little orange bit of your
prompt there what are the glyphs means
up the plus nine squiggly 2-1 bang so
this means that there are nine things
that have been added to get staging okay
who modified and one removed in my dirty
yet repository here oh that's cool so
that's just like a sort of ambien this
is this is how much changes you've
gotten how much stuff is outstanding it
hasn't here what's going on here though
what's the what's the down for then
there's four changes above me ah
okay so I'll pull them down meet oh
there's the four changes see down for
now there's four changes now here I have
one locally hit status there it is nice
cool the other question Denny de Klerk
after this one throughout our slack
Channel was the some talks you did last
year you talked about having like
diabetes and blood sugar readouts coming
up in your terminal when you're working
is that still a thing you're doing yeah
yeah so if you go to hansel and diabetes
yet we have a on some of my other
prompts i have my blood sugar happening
in my prompt in real time and that's
updated with a local service that calls
arrest endpoint updates a local text
file and then the prompt picks up that
text file but i know my blood Sugar's
and my watch now it's on my wall
I don't need to put it in there and I
can also view it you know on I can
actually go and view it like on a
website and look at it too so I'm good
either way
another thing I want to point out also
is that these websites that I play with
I actually have the exact git commit and
build and link to them at the bottom of
the website so I can go and see that was
the commit and that was the build so
anytime I'm like what is the production
running is running that pull request and
it built from that pipeline and all
that's on my blog antastic so the one
thing we've not worked out had a virtual
Asia is rounds of applause but I'm sure
that everybody around the world the 300
and we got 381 people watching this on
YouTube so thank you all of you for
tuning in thanks to we've got a little
kind of tame audience of people in the
call here because it's much easier than
talking to a webcam by yourself at what
is it two o'clock in the morning where
you are Scott it is now 2o 2 a.m. my
friends so 9th diet coke of the day on
behalf of all of the attendees the
speakers partners everyone has put this
together thank you so much for joining
us and doing that we will we will all be
hanging out online the folks who are
attending if you've got a ticket to NDC
Porto see us in the slack workspace
there's gonna be chat and stuff
happening on there to all the folks who
are watching on YouTube you should have
bought a ticket but hey we got this
thing coming up in Oslo next month so
still trying to get in for that and
thank you very much Scott we're gonna
take a short break I think I'm doing a
talk in 20 minutes so I need to go and
find it one of those webcam things
I wonder if did you think Amazon can
ship one of those to me in 15 minutes it
can't be that hard right thank you
everybody for joining that thank you
Scott have a great day and a great
conference everybody we will see all of
you online take it easy